VOICE OVER: You may remember staining slides
in biology class, dipping them in red and
purple dyes to reveal microscopic structures.
Pathologists use similar techniques to diagnose
diseases like cancer. But now researchers have
developed a new type of microscope slide that
uses nanotechnology to change the colour of cells
and reveal cancers without any staining at all
The slides, called nano-m-slides, work
using electrons embedded on their surface
that wiggle or oscillate when
they're hit with a beam of light.
As light from a microscope passes through a
piece of tissue the specific characteristics
of that tissue cause the electrons to react
in different ways and that changes the colour.
BRIAN ABBEY: We create a pattern across the entire
slide which basically makes the surface into a
a type of sensor, so your entire
microscope slide then becomes a sensor
and depending on what gets put on that sensor
different wavelengths of the ambient light are
absorbed. So if, for example, I put a healthy
cell on on our sensor it absorbs a certain set
of wavelengths and if you take a cancer
cell and you place it on this this sensor
it will absorb a different set of wavelengths
because its composition is slightly different.
V/O: The researchers aren't entirely
sure what it is about the cancer cells
that makes them show up in different colours. It
could be the density of proteins within the cell,
something about the cell skeleton or the way its
contents are organised. In this example normal
cells turn yellow and breast cancer cells
turn green. And that could allow for quick,
accurate diagnoses that could be vital in
the treatment of diseases like breast cancer
BELINDA PARKER: More and more women are
being diagnosed with really early stages of
breast cancer, for example. More women are
getting biopsies, to really look - do they
actually have cancer? Or, you know, an
earlier stage or a benign abnormality.
V/O:In a standard cancer screen -
biopsy tissue taken from the breast
must be embedded in wax, sliced very
thin, then placed on a slide and stained.
BELINDA PARKER: Usually a pathologist may be
looking at a subtle change in the shape of a cell
amongst a tissue of thousands or millions of cells
- and, you know, this nanoslide was really picking
up a difference in a cancer cell compared to
another early, sort of, change in these cells.
V/O: By eliminating the staining
step, the nano-M-slides produced
clear and accurate results
in as little as 10 minutes.
BELINDA PARKER: It was quite amazing
that we could just see these cancer cells
through a conventional microscope, so a normal
microscope would really distinguish these
cancer cells from from other surrounding cells -
including the very cells that cancer arises from.
V/O: Nano-M-slides probably won't be a
replacement for other diagnostic methods
but they could provide one
more tool to help pathologists
standardise their diagnosis of diseases,
which can sometimes be difficult to call.
BRIAN ABBEY: We see that this work as really
being the tip of the iceberg. There are
other disease states and other cancers, in fact,
that we are also pursuing as well in the meantime.
V/O: The researchers say that knowing
immediately whether a tissue is cancerous or not
could help surgeons decide which
sections of a tumour to remove.
BRIAN ABBEY: It's time critical you know, the
patient's lying on the table you need to get
a - the surgeon and the pathologist
wants to get a - result as quickly
as possible to minimise the amount
of time that the patient is under.
And these slides, because of the fact that
they don't require any chemistry in terms
of the standing or labelling, could have a huge
positive impact, I think, in that in that setting.